Thomas  you seem particularly triggered right  now can you tell me what happened  I've had dreams that weren't just dreams  am I crazy  we don't use that word in here  [Music]  hi  [Music]  have we met  [Music]  one kill makes you larger  makes you small and the ones that mother  gives you don't do anything at all Go  Ask Alice  when she's 10 feet tall  [Music]  time to fly  chasing private  we want the truth near you're going to  have to find me  [Music]  the only thing that matters to you is  still here I know it's why you're still  fighting and why you will never give up  you don't know me  no  proportions  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  Jesus  [Music]  after all these years to be going back  to where it all started back to the  Matrix  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]